egal ob ihn daher des bekleidungs
anstalt wiener hauptbahnhof oder im
hotel marriott in der wiener innenstadt
dass japan fiebert die österreichische
olympia mannschaft nun fest im griff
bemerkenswert ist die gelassenheit mit
der österreichs olympioniken nach tokio
fan in dieser woche bekommen alle
athletinnen und athleten ihre bereits
voll gefüllten reisekoffer olympische
optimismus inklusive österreich
entsendet 75 medaillenanwärter 50 davon
stellt das österreichische bundesheer
worüber sich verteidigungsministerin
klaudia tanner am hauptbahnhof
naturgemäß freut
stehen und zeigen was man alles kann
um die dafür benötigte ausrüstung wird
von den sponsoren in diese koffer
gepackt damit es in tokio auch an nichts
fehlt
training endlich fertig gepackte koffer
was fehlt da noch was kommt 1000
persönlichen dingen nokia pistole und
unseren gästen über die sap arena
und ja also glücksbringer
es kommt der reisende mit glücksbringer
die hoffentlich nicht gebraucht werden
denn die korona bedingte verschiebung
der spiele um ein jahr haben die
sportlerinnen genutzt um mit training
die sportliche leistung zu vollenden zu
bringen
ich glaube dass mal es insgesamt als
österreichische mannschaft sehr stark
aufgestellt sind
es sind wirklich sehr viele potenzielle
gewinner der sportler dort und jeder hat
die letzten jahre wirklich blut
geschwitzt
bei den spielen der wunsch nach dem
bestmöglichen ergebnis klingt nach
standardformulierung hat aber
tatsächlich einen tieferen hintergrund
man kriegt da später die rückenstärkung
also selbst jetzt in den crooner zeiten
oder ja jetzt auch noch mit den ganzen
restriktionen vergisst man sicher nicht
für welches land man an den start geht
und wenn man vertritt eigentliche große
ehre ist eine vorfreude motivation dass
es endlich losgeht rot-weiß-roter
optimismus so weit das auge reicht
sprichwörtlich träume zu leben ist jetzt
angesagt
[Musik]
erste finale das geben dieses jahr traum
ein traum den andere schon gelebt haben
siegerin tanja frank kennt bereits
dieses gefühl einer olympiamedaille
gewinnen denn olympia medaillen kann man
nie genug haben
natürlich wäre es schön viel schöne im
leben
aber genau da liegt das ganze problem
dass technische oft andere trotzdem darf
als gold silber und bronze durchaus
gehofft werden ist die österreichische
olympia auswahl dieses mal so gut
aufgestellt wie schon lange nicht mehr
ich glaube wir hatten schon lange nicht
mehr eine derart gute mannschaft mit so
viel
kandidaten die von ihrem können her eine
medaille machen können dass davon bin
ich überzeugt und ich glaube das können
sehr erfolgreichen spiele tokio trotz
dieser rahmenbedingungen werden und um
das möglich zu machen würde
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
einen zug nach tokio wohl persönlich
steuern nach dem motto mit 10.000 ps
richtung gold silber und bronze und
jetzt wenn man den sportlerinnen und
sportler in die augen schaut dann merkt
man die konzentration die spannungen und
risse sportlerin vor ein gesagt dieses
kribbeln das beginnt und für unseren